okay so the eternals ending and both the
post-credits scenes have a lot to unpack
from them the movie is stuffed with
easter eggs brand new characters and it
also fills in a lot of the history about
the mcu and its creation throughout this
video we're going to be breaking the
entire movie down and also giving our
thoughts on it as a whole the eternals
is the first mcu movie ever to end up
getting labeled as rotten i think
whether it deserves this or not is going
to be highly debated for a long time
where we fell on it well you'll have to
wait and see and from this point onwards
it's full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now if you love the video 3000 then
please smash the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe to stick around
longer than icarus without the way
welcome to the heavy spoilers show now
let's get into the eternals
okay so i want to talk about the main
plot points in the movie first before
diving into the post-credits scene but
if you want to skip ahead then time
codes are going to be linked below the
movie is packed with a lot of exposition
and it very much explores the circle of
life within a universe now like a lot of
sci-fi movies that have to fill you in
on big chunks of lore the film opens
with a block of text that tells the
story of the celestials and how they
created the universe it details arusham
who made the first sun which brought
life into the universe it was perfectly
balanced as old things should be but
then a predator species emerged which
came to be known as the deviants they
were thought to come from deep space but
we learned throughout the movie that
they were actually created by the
celestials much like the comics they
were made to protect planets from
predators but they turned against their
masters in an attempt to feed on all
life though sarisham apparently sent the
eternals from the planet olympia in
order to take them down now this turns
out to be false but we'll talk about why
that is later on in the video the
eternals arrived on our planet in 5000
bc and we're introduced to their members
which are made up of cersei icarus kingo
sprite vastos makari druid gilgamesh
ajak and dina they defeated the deviants
pretty easily but they were instructed
to remain on earth and protect the
planet over the millennia the eternals
held to take us from land dwelling
simpletons to simpletons that have
iphones and they very much integrated
with human society throughout the movie
we learned that they pretty much had a
hand in every major breakthrough in
human history and this included things
like creating the plow steam engine
atomic bomb crazy frog the birth of the
united states and the creation of 90s
pop sensation the backstreet boys now we
learned that they stayed together until
1521 which is when tina's memories got
too much for her and this fractured her
mind which sent her into attack mode she
turned on the group and thus ajax wanted
to erase her memories but she didn't go
through with this and instead the group
disbanded ajak instructed them to find
their own purposes and when they
reunited tell her what they'd found they
all kind of have their own stories but i
think kingo has by far the funniest one
he ended up becoming a bollywood actor
and even pretended to be his own
grandson and son in order to explain why
he hadn't aged he pretty much created an
entire fake family based around himself
so that he could keep acting and it's a
pretty creative backstory that i'm sure
keanu reeves is taking notes on now jurg
ended up leaving with a group of humans
in order to see if there was a way to
stop us warring he possesses the ability
to control minds and he pretty much
wants to stop the self-destructive path
that humanity is on fast dos went on to
have a family makari remained on the
ship and gilgamesh took dinner away in
order to care for her after a
relationship that lasted several
lifetimes cersei and icarus split up and
she ended up moving to england cersei
then ended up dating dane whitman who
you might know as being the black knight
from the comics sprite was sent to her
by ajax to check in to see if everything
was okay and that's pretty much where we
pick up with the characters now one big
question that was floating around about
the movie is why didn't they help to
stop thanos they ended up hanging back
like batman during the doomsday fight
and the movie actually gives a pretty
good answer the eternals were supposed
to be there to protect us from the
deviants but they also understood that
if they stepped in the way of every
single threat that it would harm our own
development nothing breeds change like a
challenge and thus they've waited on
earth until they're told that they can
return home now the present-day stuff is
where the true thrust of the movie comes
from and after an earthquake rocks the
planet a deviant emerges that has the
ability to regenerate this attacks
cersei sprite and dane and icarus
arrives in order to help out together
they then travel to ajax house to find
her dead by deviant from this point
onwards they reunite with the rest of
the group and in earth exactly what's
going on now ajax had an orb that
allowed her to communicate with arishim
and this goes into cersei which leads to
the discovery that there's a seed within
the planet this is actually an unborn
celestial and as the intelligent
population grows the sea grows along
with it once the earth gets to a certain
point the seed will be able to finally
come to fruition and the celestial will
fully form which will completely destroy
the planet this is known as the
emergence and it's something that the
celestials have carried out ever since
the dawn of time in order to birth more
of them after they're created celestials
then make new sons and galaxies and thus
the celestials must be birthed from this
destruction in order to allow the rest
of the universe to thrive we learn the
one on earth is called time it and in
the comics he's actually known as the
dreaming celestial now the earthquake
was part of the process and slowly the
pieces all start to fall into place that
finally prove that hashtag thanos was
right interestingly the avengers
bringing everyone back with the blip
actually sped up the process as the
planet suddenly thrived once more which
made everything move faster than kevin's
spoilers now we discover that the
celestials made the deviants to protect
the population of a planet but they
ended up evolving and turning against
their masters upon a planet being
destroyed the deviants were killed along
with it and thus they're trying to stop
the emergence for their own survival
this led to the celestials having to
create the eternals to take them out and
everything is very much shrouded in
shades of grey the eternals are
synthetic and therefore incapable of
evolution and thus they haven't carried
the same faults that the deviants had we
discovered that the eternals have been
complicit in the destruction of several
planets and that they've had their minds
erased after each emergence so that they
could go into more and continue to carry
out the process again dina went crazy
because her mind wasn't correctly erased
and she still carried forth some of the
memories from these past processes there
is no olympia and the eternals are all
machines that are created in the world
forge which is where their memories are
stored now i really enjoyed this
exploration into the lore and though
it's very heavy on the exposition i
enjoyed how much the movie kind of gave
each set of characters their own drives
and motivations that you could
completely understand i've seen some
reviews say that each of the characters
are underdeveloped and even one review
about this movie basically being what
would happen if the first time that we
were introduced to the avengers was in
their team-up movie i have to completely
disagree and i think that each of them
works well has their own complexities
and also their own little flaws which
makes them easy to relate to after
meeting with drag they're attacked by
the deviance leader who you may know as
being called crow from the comics he
absorbs gilgamesh and then evolves which
causes the eternal to die because of
this druid agrees to help put the
celestial and the planet to sleep so
that they can finally stop all this
chaos they got a fast dose who because
of his husband and son has realized that
humanity has good in them he agrees to
join them in order to create a uni mind
which is not only a terrible name but
it's basically something that's going to
unite them all so that they can destroy
the celestial they venture to the ship
and by makari and shortly after we learn
that icarus has been well aware of the
emergence process for a long time he
went to ajax to find that she changed
her mind about carrying it out and this
is because when they split up she
realized that humanity likes to live
laugh love now icarus betrayed her and
he fed her to the deviants he brought
everyone together to protect them from
the monsters and once his plan is
revealed he turns on the group sprite
actually leaves with him and kingo drops
out of the group because he agrees with
his point of view however he'd rather
not fight his friends and he's basically
just fencing together the remaining
eternals vow to stop icarus in the
emergence which leads to them all going
head to head crow arrives during this
and athena kills him which brings her
memories back durg is blocked from
controlling the celestial but cersei
then starts to connect to it which is
when sprite stabs her in the back she
says that because she can't grow up that
living amongst the humans was torture as
she realized she'd never be able to
really experience a full life drug
knocks her out and cersei begins to turn
the celestial to stone icarus goes to
stop her but he realizes that because he
loves her that he can't bring himself to
kill her and together they all unite to
stop the emergence after putting a halt
to the destruction icarus makes like his
namesake and flies towards the sun but
he goes all the way into the store rise
of that guy just fell to earth now
cersei uses her abilities to transform
sprite into a real girl and after a last
supper drake thinner and makari travel
into space to find more eternals cersei
and kingo watches sprite goes after
school and dane says that though he's
still trying to get his head around
everything that he loves cersei no
matter what dain teases that he has a
complicated family history and arashim
pulls the eternals into space he states
that he knows they chose the planet over
the birth of a celestial and says he
will look through their memories and
return with a judgment which will decide
whether humanity deserves to live or not
for the final scene we journey back to
earth and see dane panicking because
he's just watched his girlfriend being
pulled into space that kind of takes us
into the second post credit scene in
which we watch him debating whether he
should take an ancestral sword that
belonged to his family this is contained
in a box with medieval markings on it
and upon moving his hands towards it the
sword starts to react this is clearly
setting him up to become the black
knight a marvel hero that's been part of
groups such as the avengers and heroes
for hire throughout the history of
marvel there have been several versions
of the character which are all part of
the same family tree they passed on this
mantle down through their children and
originally whitman's uncle was a villain
this adds a lot to the complicated
history that he talks about and in the
comics dane's uncle passed the sword to
him and said that he should restore the
honor to his family that his criminality
had destroyed at one point in the comics
both he and cersei travel back in time
together and it could be possible that
the pair will indeed be going through
the ages in a future film in order to
discover the origins of the sword this
would also allow him to interact with
his ancestors and learn about all the
things that his family had done now the
sword he finds is likely the ebony blade
which like leica's family has somewhat
of a complicated nature to it though it
can bestow great power on those that can
wield it it also has a downside the
sword is cursed and if one spends too
much time wielding it they can become
violent aggressive and corrupted i think
this would make for a really good
storyline for the future and it
definitely may be a direction that they
take things in the sequels now why
something reality breaking could be
happening is because we hear a
disembodied voice asking if he's ready
i've spoken to a lot of people and no
one seems to know exactly who it is but
i actually think that it sounds a lot
like jeffrey wright aka the watcher the
watcher only tends to appear in a
universe upon something major happening
and in the comics when he arrived during
civil wars the heroes kicked their pants
because it was a signal that things
could go very badly that's also the kind
of vibe that i get from this moment and
due to the curse potentially being
placed on the blade it is possible that
this could lead to either a new defender
being created or an evil antagonist for
earth i think that we will likely get
the former over the latter but the
eternals has shown us with icarus that
things can go beyond being black and
white now the second post credit scene
picks up with the eternals in space how
we meet two brand new characters the
first is pip the troll who hails from
the planet laxadaisia pip didn't
originally look like a troll but the
character ended up drinking a liquor
that transformed him into one and thus
he was exiled from his planet after that
he traveled through the universe and
eventually ended up joining forces with
adam warlock who we now know is going to
be played by will poulter in the mcu
warlock was teased at the end of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and it is
possible that pip may appear in the
third film or that he could end up
meeting adam warlock in the next
eternals movie now pip is very much here
to introduce eros aka star fox who's
played by harry styles upon entering pip
lists off everything you need to know
about him and as he mentions he is
indeed the brother of thanos now in the
comics thanos was a citizen of titan but
the character had a deviant gene which
is what gave him his appearance thanos
wanted to bring genocide to the planet
in order to save it from destabilizing
and this led to his banishment we
haven't really seen the relationship
between eros and his brother yet and i
would love to have it shown in things
like a flashback or potentially even the
multiverse pip also states that he has
defeated black roger and he follows this
up by saying he's from the mystery
planet now black roger is likely a note
to dark roger who was the monarch of
mystery planet but after pip called him
black robert i'm not sure if he knows
the correct name anyway eros confirms
that he too is an eternal in their
greeting and this could mean that much
like the comics thanos is also one who
simply carried a deviant gene i'm not
sure how it works with them being
machines but potentially thanos was
aware of the celestial's plan and this
is why he wanted to keep the population
down to a certain amount eros is
actually the younger brother of thanos
and though initially he had no
aspirations of being a hero this changed
when one of thanos's attacks led to the
death of their mother over the years the
pair have gone head to head and he
wields several cosmic powers similar to
the eternals after relocating to earth
he joined the avengers and got the name
star fox the eternals all have their own
abilities and he can induce pleasure
amongst people which makes them obsessed
with him and oh my god
it's harry styles now eros presents a
sphere and says that though their
friends are in big trouble he knows
where to find them this clearly teases
that the eternals will continue the
search for more of their kind and i
actually think that this will lead to
them showing the rest of the eternals in
the galaxy the truth about their
missions this could lead to an all-out
war against the celestials and i think
it would be really tense if arashim
returned to earth to say that he decided
to destroy the planet this would lead to
the heroes having to unite to take him
down and i love it if galactus was
introduced through this when the trailer
first dropped a lot of people thought
that he was actually arusham and though
it's not really in line with the comics
he could end up becoming a servant of
them and that could push galactus into
destroying the planet that is a pretty
big deviation from what's in the source
material but i'm just giving fan
theories yeah and you know it's not like
i'm gonna be right anyway but they're
just fun to discuss either way i can see
them heading towards an eternals versus
celestial showdown as this movie clearly
hindered towards them being on opposite
sides of the same coin i think that in
the next entry they'll probably travel
to the forge and regain all their
memories we were told by arishim that
this is where they were kept so it makes
sense for that to be a macguffin in the
next film i think that would be a great
direction to take the series but let us
know your thoughts below if you disagree
that it's not mephisto
[Music]
now as for my thoughts i'm getting to
the point now yeah where i seem to
disagree with every single rotten
tomatoes score as i really enjoyed this
though it's the first rotten mcu movie i
think that it's way better than captain
marvel the incredible hulk black widow
iron man 2 iron man 3 thor and thor the
dark world though it has lots of weighty
exposition i found most of the
conversations to be worthwhile
philosophical ones that discussed heavy
topics like life and death on a
universal scale each of the characters
also had their own aspects to them and i
found each of the points of view
relatable in some ways now the movie is
a long one but i didn't really mind the
runtime i find with a lot of marvel
movies you can often tell i've cut stuff
out to keep things moving but it was
actually nice to just spend time with
the characters and hear what they had to
say saying that though i completely
understand that this movie won't be for
everyone and that there will be a lot of
people that just don't like it weirdly
at points it feels more like a dc movie
than a marvel one and that's even
without the references to batman and
superman i think that it's still a
pretty strong entry though and even if
it's not in my top 10 it's probably one
of my preferred origin stories because
it's not just going through the motions
like a lot of them are now with the
praise of course comes some negativity i
think that the action is lacking at some
points in the film it doesn't really
have many spectacles and a lot of the
time the battles are pretty small scale
with people just flying around and
punching the deviants there's also a lot
of characters to comprehend and i think
some of them could have been cut from
the film without us missing them at all
still though the eternals was way better
than i was expecting i don't know if
it's because i heard it was a mess that
i went in thinking it wouldn't be that
good but overall i found it surprisingly
enjoyable as we discussed on my last
june video expectations before a movie
can often decide your eventual enjoyment
so i do kind of want to sit on this for
a couple of days before i come all out
and say exactly how i feel about it this
is very much a first reaction to it and
i'm gonna see it again tomorrow which
should kind of clear up how i feel
saying that though coming straight out
of the cinema and starting to work on
this video i'm way more focused on the
positives of the movie over the
negatives i think it's going to be a
divisive film but i'm definitely in the
camp of people that enjoyed it chloe
xiao has brought something new to the
mcu and this is a philosophical movie
about what it means to be human which i
really appreciate though it's not going
to be many people's favorite i'd love to
see the eternals back and because of
that i'm scoring it a 7.5 out of 10. now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film as i can tell from the early
reactions on twitter that people are
going to be very divided leave them
below and just to let you know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
november all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want some else to watch
then make sure you check out our
brighton of the mobius trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we
went over all the easter eggs talked
about what the hell is going on with the
multiverse and also just give our
reaction to it if not then i hope you
enjoy your weekend you take care of
yourself i mean paul and i'll see you on
the next one i'm out [ __ ] peace